how long were you at this classified
assignment for uh
let's see six years i did uh
a year at navy uh newport okay that's
where i met colin green we were next
door neighbors
and uh so i did that and from 96
till 02. then i went back to the 160th
and was um exo of first battalion and
then end up commanding a couple years
later so when september 11th goes down
you're in newport
going to war college or something no i
was in
budapest on an exercise
when it happened um we were over there
doing a
uh you know it was one of those i think
it was like a loose nuke kind of thing
you know
exercise uh and that's where i was and
then you know a few
a few weeks later i was deployed you
know
i won't go to the deal but i was
deployed into pakistan and then
basically you know the world changed for
all of us after that you know
so when when you started doing missions
when you where when did you get back to
the 160th
uh i got back to the 160th in
[Music]
june of it was right around father's day
of uh
oh two and then you know
i took over as the executive officer of
first of the 160th
which is you know the the biggest
battalion there and that's where i grew
up
and then we ended up you know a few
months later two months later i was in
afghanistan did back two back-to-back
tours and then we invaded iraq
how long were your tours over there um
back then we were doing i was doing
about
i did 60 days was back for 30 days and
went back for another 60 days
and then i came back because we had an
alert package so you had to mod
you had to have that ready to go so
when i wasn't forward i was back sitting
on alert and then i ended up in iraq in
may
so what kind of ops were you running in
afghanistan were you were you flying as
the xo
yeah oh yeah yeah it was uh it was it
was fun now
afghanistan i mean that's some
challenging flying right over there i
mean you know that that you know that
place is like they don't call it the
rooftop of the world for nothing i mean
i used i was very you know my fondest
saying and i still say it you know
if you compare iraq to afghanistan
the enemy in iraq is the enemy it's the
insurgents right i mean the terrain is
except for those you know biblical dust
storms over there i mean it's not
very challenging terrain you know it's
usually not very it's usually
predictable too
yeah it's gonna be hot hot yeah in the
winter time it's gonna be cold but it's
pretty it's pretty predictable yeah but
afghanistan i mean you know
europe at the highest altitudes i mean
everybody's running on the
little birds were essentially worthless
over there you know if they were
carrying anything and
the chinooks ended up being the heavy
lifter for us to insert
ops up and you know way up into hindu
kush i mean blackhawks couldn't even do
it
so very very challenging flying there in
the early days you know they were
launching out of k2 out of karshikanabad
in uzbekistan going north into
so is it like when you're flying at that
altitude a helicopter is it like you're
driving on on like wet
pavement where you just don't get the
reactions that you would normally get
yeah i mean it depends on the altitude
the aircraft is not as responsive
but where where you really pay the price
is if you get
when you're doing an approach in there i
mean you got to closely manage your
power
or you're going to get in trouble if you
let momentum develop on that descent in
the approach
i mean you don't have the power to go
around you know you're committed
regardless of the enemy situation so
it's just really
you're just very very limited on the uh
on on power and options up at altitude
so you know i remember flying missions
up
14 15 000 feet so you got to be on o2
with 47's and there you know their
allowable load was like eight guys in a
chinook
i mean usually it's plus or minus a ton
in those things right i mean you know
just keep packing them in i've seen a
hundred rangers in a chinook before
and you're down to eight eight when you
guys knew
did you have any time to say hey we
better go start flying
you know around the rocky mountains nope
just figuring later we did later we'd
start prepping we'd go out in fact we
lost an airplane at mount mass of
colorado guys training up to go in there
i lost four guys i was a commander at
the time but in the initial days no
nothing because you know it was a come
as you are deal so do you
know i just knowledge that you know like
okay well we're at altitude this is
going to suck yeah
well i mean you do the performance
planning right so you get you understand
what the aircraft can and most
more importantly can't do at those
altitudes so
but you're you know you're sort of in
denial at those numbers you know
i mean i never thought i'd say eight
guys in a chinook
plus you had to deal with the brown out
that dust was just
really really bad worse in the southern
parts down in
helmand and down in those areas around
kandahar
less so up in uh you know up in the
hindu cush mountains up in the north but
you know i mean it was
brutal flying brutal and
so you when you first got over there
your first deployment what's your op
temple like
um so i got over there the first time i
was there
i think september of 02
or august of 02 through maybe october
or maybe november i can't remember but
um
we did a fair amount of missions and um
and then you know i the last next time i
went over there i think i was there in
january now i left december i remember i
left december right before christmas
30 days to the day i was right back in
the same crappy little tent
up there at bagram you know with rain
water i mean it was just
water running through it and everything
uh and then from
january through march because you know
they were spinning up at the latter part
of that to go into iraq right
uh we don't got the word we're going in
and um we didn't do much i mean because
weather was really crappy i did a couple
of missions
uh some pretty challenging ones way way
up in the uh
in some areas that were very tricky
for aviation in fact i one i was so high
in uh
in a place called cantiga that we
couldn't have any fire support
i mean the airplanes wouldn't perform so
i just
elected to stay on the x right we
infield and i
got the ground force commander so give
me a couple guys cover our blind spots
and uh we're just going to go to ground
idle while you guys clear and get
whatever you're getting and then hop
back in and we'll
normally you know you know the deal we
come in we land drop off and then split
we did we just stayed and you know
pulled the engines back because i didn't
i didn't want to
it took us two hour turn to go get gas
down the hill and come back and i
didn't want to leave him up there for
that long so we said hey we'll just hang
out how long are you on the ground for
uh about 45 minutes to an hour it wasn't
that bad
it was cold though i mean it was
freezing snow and everything else up
there was
like i said february or something
how at what point did you uh notice that
people were just
like this is what we're this is what
we're doing this is the new reality
you know when i talk to you you know you
were talking about i was talking about
the mindset you know when you did panama
and then you did desert storm and you
you're not quite there yet you know
you're yeah you're not quite there yet
and then you know we were talking
earlier uh my first deployment to iraq
it's like oh we're doing another you
know it's like oh yeah we're doing
another op this is just what we're doing
it's just like
becomes normal yeah um
i think that really you know there was
the op tempo the operational tempo in
afghanistan
wasn't that bad just because of the
terrain
and the planning and we didn't have all
the isr back then you know we didn't
have all that
all the you know the tools to give us
good situational awareness on targets
like
we ended up having in iraq where i saw
that it was
we really became just sort of another
day at the office was in iraq so i went
over in may
and i'll never forget my boss this may
have o3
got it so my boss you know they had
punched up there around march or so
i think you know they did that big win
into baghdad international airport
i came in and i you know the xo is sort
of the
you know he's the guy in charge of all
the staff and
you know logistics and all that kind of
stuff and my boss said hey come over
here
we're we're going to be out of here in
30 days i just want you to make sure we
got property accountability and you get
all your stuff and get out and i was
like
you know i mean i hadn't been to iraq so
i'm like sign me up chief i'm in you
know
yeah so i showed up there
and of course you know 30 days never
happened but
man i mean the best time i mean we did
we did some ops that were just
incredible i mean the op temple was
really really
high i mean we were banging targets we
did an op um
it's been in several magazines op
reindeer
it was a bunch of bunch of foreign
fighters had gathered they were getting
ready to split up and attack
coalition bases with teams of three
and uh we got the intel on and went in
with a half gaff
kind of thing you know helicopter saw
fours for the audience in ground assault
force on each side of this wadi
and i mean it was it was game on i mean
it went on we fought for about
two hours killed about a hundred of them
a young ranger took an rpg below the
knee
uh you know we cast a vacuum i'm still
in touch with him matt waters he's up in
tacoma as a cop right now freaking out
yeah he is he's he's stud i mean uh
second range of the time beco
275 was the unit i mean i was a mission
of a lifetime you know i was
i was uh air mission commander riding a
jump seat of a 47 tracer we were coming
in underneath the tracer fireman it was
awesome
in fact that was the tracer fire was
coming out my left side you know of
course your chest plates
meant to protect your chest i was
loosening up my side strap
and slid it around this way like i'm
going to get clipped it's going to be
over here
you know but just a great mission ah6 is
just
crushing them and it was a fight went on
for a couple hours did a lot of
engagements
shooting them fours out of the side of
the because the rangers were so close to
the enemy
that we didn't want to use mini guns
because the ricochet so we just hover in
there and the ah6 guys would take them
out with uh
m4s and peck twos and all that so it was
a good that
remains the best mission i ever did it
was awesome and so this is
st this is in like that was june 11
2003 got it yeah and this is now
now we're getting into legit op tempo
this is what we're doing
reload get jocked up again we're going
out tomorrow here's the next target
it went from that till you know you
flash forward now a couple years later
right prior to the surge and we were
running we'd be running
seven eight ops a night i mean i'd have
those big screen tvs and isr
tracking multiple ops out of out of uh
blood and i mean it was just non-stop
so you went for 30 days how long did you
end up staying for
well he said it was going to be 30 days
so i left in august
so i was there about 90 or so and then i
came back was back for two months and
then i went over there for christmas and
spent you know another 60 and then i i
you know a lot of guys can tell you how
many times they're over there i don't i
have no idea i just lost track i mean
that was just you know it was back and
forth back and forth and
at what point did you go were you exo
the whole time or did you eventually
fleet up and
no so the army does it a little
different and
[Music]
so i was exo from 2002
to 2004 and then to command
first to the 160th it's a special board
called the special mission unit board
that meets
and you have to have commanded another
05 level command before that
so i got selected and went over to
germany and commanded for two years over
in germany which was you know
a great i wouldn't call it a breather
you know commands command but
i didn't deploy and so i you know the
family and i
you know drank a bunch of heffies and
ate a bunch of chocolate
and you know it looked like my wife's
like
man this camera makes us look fat oh
yeah that's definitely yeah